Il m'en manque beaucoup
pour arriver là où je travail.
On n'est même pas à la moitié,
on est encore loin.
Il reste beaucoup de chemin.
Andres Vargas, 35 ans.
Voilà 2 h qu'il progresse vers son filon
dans une des galeries de la mine Bolivar.
L'air libre est à deux kilomètres.
Andres Vargas avait 17 ans lorsqu'il
est descendu pour la première fois,
dans les entrailles
de la Cordillère des Andes,
au cœur de la Bolivie.
Je travaille depuis 18 ans
dans cette mine.
J'y ai laissé toute ma jeunesse.
Au début, ce travail,
c'était comme un jeu.
Cette poussière était douce.
Et alors, comme ça...
J'ai continué et continué de travailler.
Cette coca quand j'étais jeune,
je n'en mâchait pas.
Un jour ma mère, paix à son âme,
ma mère m'a dit :
"Mon fils, pourquoi
ne mâches-tu pas de la coca ?
Si tu ne mâches pas de la coca,
tu ne tiendras pas dix ans à la mine !"
Le filon, c'est là où je tape.
C'est ici, entre le marron et le gris.
C'est ça le filon.
Et ici, là, c'est le minerai.
Ces déchets là ne servent à rien.
En six ans, j'ai avancé de 30 mètres.
En fait, je ne sais pas vraiment
à quoi il sert ce minerai.
Le Tungstène.
Je ne sais pas.
Mais que vous a-t-on dit ?
On m'a dit que cela sert
pour la poudre, pour les munitions.
Chaque jour, Andres Vargas
passe 10 h dans sa mine,
et la moitié au moins à cogner
pour extirper le tungstène.
Ce minerai ne sert pas
à faire des munitions.
Il est utilisé dans la fabrication
d'alliages très résistants.
L'entrée de la mine
est à 3800 mètres d'altitude.
Tous les soirs, vers 22 h, les poumons
d'Andres retrouvent l'air pur,
très pur des montagnes andines.
Sa maison se trouve
3 kilomètres plus loin.
Lorsqu'il rentre, ses six enfants
dorment, presque tous.
En 10 h, Andres vient
de gagner 75 francs.
Tout juste de quoi nourrir
les huit membres de la famille.
Depuis quelques jours,
sa femme Berta, est à l'hôpital.
C'est comme ça que je vis, humblement.
C'est triste la vie d'un mineur.
Je ne veux pas que mes enfants restent ici.
Je ne veux pas qu'ils vivent comme moi,
qu'ils soient mineurs.
Je veux qu'ils s'en sortent.
Qu'ils partent à la ville.
Ne pleure pas, mon enfant.
C'est très triste la mine.
Le village de Kami.
Andres y est né.
Il y vit encore.
4000 mètres d'altitude.
Au départ, dans les années 30, il n'y avait
que la mine et un campement pour les mineurs.
Plus tard, lorsque tout marchait,
il y eut près de 10 000 habitants.
Aujourd'hui, Kami est abandonné.
L'effondrement des cours
du minerai, la crise,
les mineurs ne sont plus que 250.
Andres a un surnom
El Diablo, le diable.
La fille ainée d'Andres, 17 ans.
Tiens, Catherine.
Tu as eu du thé ?
- Tu as eu du thé ?
- Non.
Je vais te sevir.
Bon, les enfants, je pars travailler.
J'espère que votre mère sortira
de l'hôpital aujourd'hui.
Si dieu le veut,
elle sera là cet après-midi.
Bon, j'y vais. Au revoir, un bisou.
Chaque semaine, Andres fait ses courses,
il va faire ses provisions de coca,
la feuille sacrée des Incas,
nettement plus fort que le café,
c'est le dopant que tous
les travailleurs mâchent en Bolivie.
Il leur coupe la faim, la soif,
et permet d'encaisser
les efforts en altitude.
- Je voudrais de la coca.
- Combien ?
2 livres.
- Laquelle ?
- Celle de la Paz.
Voilà.
C'est bon, il m'en faudrait
encore une livre.
Et de l'alcool.
L'alcool qu'on leur vend,
pratiquement pur, 90 degrés.
Je viens d'acheter un kilo de coca,
je l'ai payé 24 francs.
Combien en consommez-vous par semaine ?
Unelivre et demie.
Un sac et la moitié d'un autre.
Avant 1985, Andres était fonctionnaire.
Les mines étaient gérées par l'Etat.
Elles ont été privatisées.
Quelques multinationales
ont acheté les plus rentables.
Celle de Kami ne l'était pas.
Elle n'a pas trouvé acquéreur.
- Bonjour, compagnons.
- Bonjour.
Bonjour, le diable.
Pour continuer, les mineurs
ont créé une coopérative.
Ils travaillent à leur compte.
- Elle vient de la Paz ?
- Bien sûr.
- Il faut que ce soit de la bonne.
- On va partager.
Avant, nous les mineurs,
on travaillait pour l'État.
À chaque grève,
l'État était obligé de nous écouter.
On avait les moyens de bloquer le pays.
À cette époque,
les mineurs vivaient bien.
"Mineurs ! Unis !
Jamais ne seront vaincus ! "
10 ans après la privatisation,
la puissante corporation des mineurs,
la fierté du pays, celle dont tout
ouvrier bolivien rêvait de faire partie,
n'était plus grand chose.
Les mineurs ne faisaient
plus peur aux autorités.
Ils n'étaient plus unis, plus puissants.
Leur arme, la dynamite,
n'était plus qu'un pétard.
Ils étaient déjà vaincus.
Ils se savaient abandonnés.
Ici, l'État ne fait rien. Tout ce que l'on
voit a été fait par nous les mineurs.
Il n'y a pas un fil électrique
qui ait été posé par l'État.
Pas un seul camion
qui ait été donné par l'État.
Il n'y a rien, pas un mètre de chemin.
Ici, ce sont les mineurs
qui ont tout fait.
Chacun travaille pour lui.
Cela veut dire que si aujourd'hui
je ne descends pas à la mine,
personne ne me paye.
Je n'aurais même pas de quoi manger.
Si je veux avoir de quoi donner
à manger à mes enfants, un peu de pain,
Il faut que je sorte au moins
un kilo de minerai par jour.
Une fois par semaine, l'entrée dans
la mine prend des allures de procession.
D'ailleurs, c'est par une cérémonie
que démarre leur journée.
La cérémonie au diable.
Le diable, c'est cette pierre.
La mine, c'est son royaume.
Il faut le mettre de son côté et lui
faire partager tout ce que l'on a.
cigarettes et coca.
Aide-nous dans notre travail.
Donne-nous au moins
2 ou 3 sacs de minerai.
Accorde-nous aussi ta confiance.
À la vôtre.
C'est une tradition
qui vient de nos ancêtres.
Nos grands-pères et nos pères
faisaient comme nous.
Tous les mineurs de Bolivie célèbrent
la S**** pour le diable.
À la vôtre, compagnon !
La cérémonie dure 2 h.
2 h à mastiquer la coca
et de l'alcool à 90.
Ce sont les conquistadors espagnols qui
ont offert au sujet du grand Inca,
l'alcool et la d****,
l'ivresse et l'euphorie.
Seule potion qui permet à Andres
de rejoindre son filon,
à plus d'une heure de ses compagnons.
Seul remède contre la peur
d'être pris sous un éboulement.
Je travaille seul, toujours seul.
Je m'y suis habitué.
C'est plus dangereux que si l'on
est deux ou trois en cas d'éboulement.
Si ça m'arrive, qui va me sortir de là ?
Je pense tout le temps à ma famille.
Je pense sans arrêt qu'Andres
peut avoir un accident.
J'y pense toute la journée.
Quand il arrive tard. Quand il m'a dit qu'il
rentrerait tôt et qu'il ne vient pas...
Je ne peux pas m'empêcher de penser
qu'il lui est arrivé quelque chose.
La mine m'a déjà pris
mon frère et mon père.
Mon frère est mort à 23 ans
dans un éboulement.
Et mon père à 45 ans,
de la maladie de la mine.
La mine, c'est très dangereux.
Tant qu'Andres n'est pas rentré,
je m'attends à ce qu'on m'annonce
qu'il lui est arrivé quelque chose.
Comme attendu, Berta, la femme
d'Andres, est sortie de l'hôpital,
cet après-midi là.
Elle a retrouvé ses enfants,
les tâches ménagères, rien de tout cela
ne lui fait oublier l'angoisse.
Le plus dangereux après les éboulements,
c'est lorsqu'on fait sauter la dynamite.
Parce que les mèches sont trop courtes.
Elle brûle très vite !
Alors, il faut se dépêcher
pour se mettre à l'abri.
Je veux que mes enfants
fassent des études.
Pour qu'ils puissent trouver
un travail à la ville.
Je ne veux pas
qu'ils restent à la mine.
C'est pour cela qu'on se sacrifie
pour leurs études.
Nous avons pris la décision
de partir d'ici.
D'aller vivre à la ville.
Mais il faut qu'Andres
y trouve du travail.
Aller à la ville pour Andres, c'est perdre
plusieurs journées de travail dans la mine.
C'est moins d'argent
encore pour les enfants.
Mais sa décision est prise.
D'autant qu'il a ressenti le besoin
de passer une visite médicale.
Je pars à la ville,
car j'ai un rendez-vous avec un médecin.
Et je vais en profiter pour chercher
du travail dans un chantier.
Parce qu'après la mine, nous les mineurs,
on ne sait rien faire d'autre.
À bientôt, ma petite Bertha,
à bientôt les filles !
Reviens-nous vite.
Ne vous inquiétez pas, je reviens vite.
L'air est pur mais rare à 4000 mètres.
Il y a des mois qu'Andres s'inquiète.
Il sent qu'il le respire
de plus en plus difficilement.
La plupart des habitants
du village sont partis.
Depuis que le prix du minerai est tombé.
Toutes ces maisons sont vides.
Tout est abandonné.
Ça me fait de la peine
de voir mon village comme ça.
Mais il faut que je parte, moi aussi.
C'est triste un village sans vie.
Il faut d'abord marcher 4 km
pour arriver à  Villahermosa
et rejoindre la route
où on peut trouver des camions.
Un seul bus par semaine
sur la grande route.
Il vaut mieux compter sur les camions.
Cette route est dangereuse,
très étroite !
Si on tombe dans un ravin,
on a peu de chance de s'en sortir.
Le dernier accident,
c'est un bus qui a glissé.
Il n'y a pas eu de survivant.
Il y a eu 13 ou 15 morts.
Toute une journée
pour arriver à Oruro, la ville.
Je suis perdu ici.
Ça fait neuf ans
que je n'y étais pas venu.
J'ai du mal à trouver mon chemin.
Bonsoir.
- Vous avez une chambre ?
- Oui.
- C'est combien la nuit ?
- 10 francs.
- D'où venez-vous ?
- De Kami.
Vous êtes mineur.
Merci, monsieur.
Ça vous change
beaucoup Andres ?
Qu'est-ce qui est différent ?
Tout est différent.
Les lits, la propreté,
c'est joli ici !
Demain matin...
Je dois aller me faire
examiner par le médecin.
Pour savoir si j'ai le mal ou pas.
Moi, je me sens très mal.
"Journées obscures,
nuits pour pleurer,
désespoir et désillusion
remplissent mon âme.
C'est ma vie, je suis mineur.
Un mineur fier de son pays."
Sur la route du dispensaire,
un coup d'œil sur les chantiers.
S'il veut quitter la mine et Kami,
c'est par là qu'il devra passer.
Je suis mineur,
je chercher du travail en ville.
Vous auriez quelque chose pour moi ?
En ce moment, on n'a rien,
mais il faut voir.
Vous seriez manœuvre.
Il faudrait que vous repassiez lundi.
On aura quelque chose à vous faire faire.
D'accord.
C'est payé combien ?
Au début, un manœuvre,
ce n'est pas beaucoup.
20 francs par jour.
Avec 75 francs au village,
il nourrit à peine sa famille.
Avec 20 francs ici, il faudrait
que ses enfants travaillent.
Plus d'école, pour eux aucune
chance de s'en sortir.
Là, je suis complètement perdu.
- C'est par là.
- Où il y a le taxi ?
Non, juste à côté de l'homme
qui est debout.
Merci, madame.
Ces traces que vous voyez là,
c'est la silice.
Vous avez une silicose.
Mon conseil, Andres,
c'est d'arrêter immédiatement
votre travail de mineur.
Et de faire un traitement.
Votre espérance de vie est très faible.
Cinq ans au maximum.
C'est l'hypothèse la plus optimiste,
mais si vous continuez à la mine,
c'est un...
Au plus, deux ans.
J'ai le cœur qui brûle.
Le médecin m'a confirmé
que j'étais foutu.
Ça me fait très mal...
C'est très dur.
Et d'imaginer ma famille à la rue aussi.
Il faut que je sorte de cette mine
d'une façon ou d'une autre.
Je ne veux pas que mes enfants
restent à la mine comme moi.
Parce que la mine, je sais ce que c'est.
Je ne veux plus de ça.
Des mines en Bolivie,
il y en a encore des dizaines,
certaines sont moins abandonnées
que Kami, celle d'Andres.
Llallagua, aujourd'hui encore,
10 000 mineurs,
l'une des plus importantes exploitations
d'étain du continent,
l'une de celles
où il y a le plus d'accidents.
Comme pour Andres, les mineurs
se sont réunis en coopérative,
sinon c'était la fermeture.
Ici, on purifie le minerai comme du temps
de la colonisation espagnole.
Rien n'a changé.
45 000 habitants dans la ville,
beaucoup de veuves.
À Llallagua, elles ont un surnom,
Palliris
peut-être le mot français, paillette.
Car pour survivre,
elles n'ont qu'une ressource,
les miettes, les paillettes de minerai
oubliées par les mineurs.
Je ramasse la poussière d'étain.
C'est ce que les hommes ont laissé ?
Ils ne l'ont pas fait exprès.
En fait, je suis en train de la ramasser
sans que le propriétaire le voit.
Je la vole.
Maintenant je file !
Dona Marta.
Trois enfants, 29 ans.
La dernière Palliris,
la dernière sur la liste des veuves.
Mon mari est enterré là.
Ici, c'est mon beau-père.
Et là, un de mes enfants.
Le mari de Dona Marta,
est mort il y a dix jours.
Il avait 32 ans.
Il est tombé dans un trou
au fond d'une galerie.
Notre compagnon est tombé dans ce trou
qui sert à dégager le minerai.
Il a fait une chute de 30 mètres.
Il était mort lorsqu'on a pu le sortir.
Quels sont les autres dangers ?
Le plus courant,
ce sont les éboulements.
Après, il y a les électrocutions.
Les installations électriques
sont en très mauvais état.
Il y a de l'eau partout.
Les mineurs s'électrocutent
très fréquemment.
Et c'est vrai pour toutes
les mines de la région.
Il y a des poches de gaz où l'homme
meurt en moins de cinq minutes.
Ce sont des gaz asphyxiants.
Tout, pourrit.
Les coopératives n'ont plus
les moyens d'entretenir.
Alors les diables ont le champ libre.
Quatre morts par mois
en moyenne à Llallagua.
Ces coopératives n'ont même pas
de quoi aider les familles des tués.
Marta et ses trois enfants.
Depuis dix jours, elle n'a plus d'argent.
Pour les coopérateurs
qui sont morts dans un accident,
On prend en charge les frais
d'enterrement, soit 600 francs.
C'est tout ce qu'on peut faire.
La seule aide.
Au dessus du village, la mine siglo XX.
XXᵉ siècle.
Elle avait été baptisée ainsi au XIXᵉ siècle.
Elle devait être le symbole d'un avenir
florissant et moderne.
Ici, les mineurs font les trois-huit.
À chaque relève, un millier d'hommes
s'enfoncent dans les galeries.
De la coca pour tout le monde.
Des sacs pleins.
On est à 4000 mètres d'altitude.
À 7 h 30, le matin, le thermomètre
ne dépasse pas le zéro.
Nikos, son père était mineur.
Son grand-père aussi.
Chaque matin, comme tout le monde, il fait
ses provisions. Coca et alcool à 90 degrés.
Nikos a 18 ans.
Il a déjà passé quatre années au fond.
Il est 8 h du matin
et je ressortirai à 17 h.
C'est tous les jours pareils ?
Oui, tous les jours.
Combien de jours vous travaillez ?
Sept jours sur sept.
Presque 10 h par jour.
Un puits de 145 mètres de profondeur.
Sept paliers.
Un tous les 35 mètres.
À chacun, des galeries qui mènent
jusqu'aux boyaux, un gruyère.
La première fois que je suis
descendu, j'ai eu peur.
Ça m'a fait vomir.
Nikos travaille au troisième
palier à -105 m,
le royaume du Diable.
Une fois par semaine, un rituel.
La cérémonie au diable.
- Comment ça va les diables ?
- Bonjour, les diables.
Salut...
S'il vous plaît, faites que tout
se passe bien pour moi.
Aidez-moi.
Ici, je crois dans le diable,
parce que la mine, c'est son royaume.
À l'extérieur, je crois en Dieu.
Le diable m'aide dans mon travail.
Il me donne de la force, du courage.
Il fait que mon filon est meilleur.
En fait, c'est pour sortir plus de minerai,
et comme ça j'ai plus d'argent
pour ma famille.
L'alcool, on le fait brûler pour faire
disparaître quelques degrés,
on le dilue avec un peu de soda.
Reste que dans la gorge,
le liquide à pas loin de 80 degrés.
Je n'ai pas peur de devenir alcoolique.
À l'extérieur de la mine,
ma conscience m'empêche de boire.
Ici, c'est pour respecter la tradition.
500 mètres de galeries,
un étayage prêt à s'écrouler.
Ensuite, les boyaux.
Au fond se trouvent l'étain.
Le plus dur, ce sont
les 15-20 dernières minutes,
parce qu'il faut se traîner.
À mon poste, on tient maximum 1 h
à cause de la température.
Pour en sortir le plus possible,
je vais jusqu'au bout,
jusqu'à l'épuisement
pour un peu de minerai.
Impossible de faire demi-tour
dans le boyau de Nikos.
Pour en sortir,
il n'a que la marche arrière.
Température ambiante : 50 degrés.
Le problème ici, c'est que ce n'est pas
solide, c'est friable.
Ça se défait tout seul.
Alors, je prends un risque si
je gratte trop, ça s'effondre sur moi.
Il faut savoir s'arrêter pour ne pas être
enseveli et ne pas se faire écraser.
Au même instant à l'air libre,
le reste de notre équipe de tournage prend
en charge un jeune mineur affolé.
Le boyau dans lequel
il creusait s'est effondré.
Il n'a pas réussi à dégager
son compagnon enseveli.
Depuis quand il est enseveli ?
Ça fait 3 heures.
C'est ici.
Sa préoccupation : prévenir
la femme du mineur enseveli.
William est enterré dans la mine.
Il est complètement enseveli,
je ne sais pas quoi faire.
- C'est pas vrai !
- Si, c'est la vérité.
- Qu'est-ce qu'on va faire ?
- Tout seul, je n'y arrive pas.
Papa, William est enterré !
Où est ton père ?
Il faut qu'il parte à la mine,
William est enterré, vite !
Il faut qu'il m'aide !
Où est Roberto ?
Dépêche-toi ! Il faut y aller !
M**** !
Vite, ma lampe !
Je ne sais pas la fermer, papa !
Roberto, c'est le beau-frère de William,
l'homme enseveli.
J'ai essayé d'enlever des pierres.
Mais William m'a dit :
" Va plutôt chercher de l'aide,
ça risque encore de s'éffondrer."
Comment peut-on y accéder ?
Peut-être en contournant
par un autre côté.
Dans son boyau, Nikos ne sait toujours pas
qu'à quelques dizaines de mètres de lui,
un homme est emmuré.
Voilà 4 h que l'éboulement s'est produit.
Le problème de Nikos : sortir son minerai.
50 kilos d'étain brut.
Il est 16 h 30. Pour Nikos,
la journée ne s'achève pas encore.
Il doit aller vendre le contenu de son sac,
c'est son salaire pour la semaine.
A la sortie du trou,
les secours s'organisent.
En fait, la famille organise le secours.
Premier problème,
trouver de la coca.
Je n'ai plus de coco,
peut-être là-bas.
D'accord, j'y vais.
Que se passe t-il ?
On n'a pas de coca
pour aller sauver William,
et on ne peut pas descendre
sans coca, on en a besoin.
17 h. Nikos apprend la nouvelle.
Voilà 5 h que William est enseveli.
- Il est de ta famille ?
- C'est mon cousin.
L'une des plus grandes mines de Bolivie
et pas d'équipes de secours,
juste les hommes de la famille et Nikos.
Sauvetage ou pas,
le rituel est incontournable.
La coca pour se donner des forces.
- Tu vas nous aider ?
- Je vais essayer.
Nikos n'en a pas besoin,
il a mâché pendant des heures.
Seulement, il ne connait pas ce boyau.
D'ailleurs personne ne le connait
car William s'est fait ensevelir,
alors qu'il cherchait un nouveau filon.
En fait, ce boyau mène
à d'autres boyaux, un labyrinthe.
Ils vont nous envoyer
plus d'alcool et de coca.
On va mâcher, boire et prier,
et puis on va y retourner.
Je ne sais pas où il est.
Je n'ai pas réussi à le trouver.
Il y a beaucoup de trous et de poussière.
Je ne sais pas où il est.
Nikos a décidé d'abandonner.
Il a déjà passé plus de 10 h au fond.
Mais surtout,
l'étain qu'il a extrait aujourd'hui,
c'est son salaire pour la semaine.
En fait, son patron, le propriétaire
du filon où il travaille,
ne le paie pas en argent mais lui laisse
le droit de piocher pour son compte,
le septième jour de la semaine.
Si Nico ne vend pas son minerai
aujourd'hui, pas de salaire pour lui,
et pas d'argent pour sa famille
pendant toute une semaine.
Les acheteurs ne prennent
que l'étain purifié.
Alors, comme son père et son grand-père le
faisaient avant lui,
pendant près de 2 h, Nikos et un de
ses camarades vont broyer leurs minerais,
pour séparer le métal de la gangue.
Combien de kilos en tout ?
60 kilos.
Combien on vous l'achète ?
550.
550 francs.
On doit les partager entre nous deux.
275 francs par semaine.
Un seul salaire pour six personnes.
La mère, le père, Nikos
et ses trois petits frères.
Tiens, maman, voilà ce que j'ai gagné.
Pour ton argent de poche.
On verra ça plus tard.
Papa, regarde,
c'est l'argent de la semaine.
C'est pas mal,
mais ça risque d'être juste
pour la semaine.
Ma mère dit qu'elle est fière de moi.
De mon travail parce que je vais m'en sortir.
Elle est au bord des larmes.
Moi, je fais ça pour elle,
pour mon père
et pour mes petits frères.
Je veux qu'ils s'en sortent.
Qu'ils ne souffrent pas
comme moi à la mine.
William est enseveli depuis 8 h.
Damien, son jeune compagnon
qui a donné l'alerte,
a réussi à retrouver
le lieu de l'éboulement.
William est localisé.
Il se trouve à quelques mètres
derrière ses pierres.
Combien ? On ne sait pas.
William !
Ça y est, on n'est pas loin !
On va te sortir de là !
- Vous l'avez entendu ?
- Oui, on lui a parlé.
- Alors, où c'est ?
- Par là-bas, il faut monter.
- Et c'est comment ?
- Il y a d'énormes pierres.
Énormes !
- Vous l'avez entendu ?
- Oui, il parle, il crie.
- On l'entend pleurer.
- Il pleure.
Beaucoup de poussière.
Mais il faut continuer à déblayer.
Le problème,
ce sont les grosses pierres.
Toujours pas de sauveteurs officiels.
Les hommes de la famille
et quelques amis de William,
se relaient pour déblayer le boyau.
Sylvia, la femme de William.
Elle a pris en charge
le ravitaillement des sauveteurs.
Cigarettes, alcool et coca.
Dans le poncho accroché à son dos,
son dernier né, trois mois.
Vous avez de la coca,
les cigarettes, l'alcool ?
- Oui, j'ai tout acheté.
- C'est le plus important.
S'il vous plait,
aidez mon mari, sortez le de là.
On m'a dit qu'on l'entendait parler.
Il faut l'aider.
Ne vous inquiétez pas,
il y a des gens qui l'aident.
Ce matin, quand il est parti, il m'a dit
qu'il allait travailler pour quelques francs.
20 francs pour nos enfants.
Combien d'enfants avez-vous ?
J'ai quatre enfants.
4 h du matin. L'éboulement
s'est produit il y a seize heures.
Ne partez pas.
Aidez-le, s'il vous plaît.
Il faut encore dégager au moins
2 mètres de caillasse pour sortir William.
Il faut surtout aller chercher de l'aide,
mais on est tous épuisés ici.
Il faut se reposer
pour recommencer demain.
On ne peut plus rien
faire pour le moment.
Sa famille est partie.
- Personne ne dégage ?
- Non, plus personne.
Ils sont partis alors
qu'ils devraient encore être là.
- Personne ne bosse ?
- Non, personne.
S'il vous plaît, restez.
Il n'y a plus que moi qui vais rester.
À quelques mètres sous
ces pierres, William,
mais plus personne pour les déplacer.
À 4 h 30 à l'extérieur,
les plus proches tentent d'expliquer
à Sylvia leur impuissance.
Je connais l'endroit où il est.
C'est compliqué.
Il lui reste de l'air,
mais il est complètement enseveli.
C'est très instable.
On n'y arrive pas, on n'avance pas.
Il y a des pierres énormes.
On a fait ce qu'on a pu.
La poussière nous empêche d'avancer.
C'est grave.
Il y a trop de poussière.
5 h du matin, son bébé toujours
arrimé sur son dos,
Sylvia décide de tenter autre chose,
de faire venir d'autres énergies.
Son idée ? Un appel à la radio locale,
celle que les mineurs écoutent au réveil.
"William Casore,
qui travaille à la mine Siglo XX,
est enseveli depuis hier au niveau 11-4.
Son épouse, Silvia, nous dit :
que ses compagnons
n'ont pas réussi à le sauver.
Il est allé à la mine hier,
alors qu'il ne devait pas travailler.
J'appelle tous ceux qui le
connaissent à venir l'aider.
Cette nuit, ils ne sont pas
arrivés à le sortir.
Là, plus personne n'essaye.
Je vous en supplie, venez m'aider.
7 h du matin.
Il y a 19 h que William est enseveli.
Apparemment, l'appel de Sylvia
n'a pas été entendu.
Les dirigeants de la mine semblent
quand même se réveiller,
mais leur empressement à organiser
les secours ne saute pas aux yeux.
Nous, les dirigeants, nous sommes en train
d'organiser le sauvetage de notre compagnon.
Mais cela fait 18 h qu'il est enseveli.
Permettez-moi de vous expliquer.
Cela peut vous paraître étrange,
mais la mine est grande.
Il faut d'abord localiser le mineur. On ne
sait pas exactement où a eu lieu l'éboulement.
Nous, nous savons où il se trouve depuis
hier 3 h de l'après-midi.
Si, nous avons filmé
le lieu de l'accident.
Dedans ?
Les dirigeants ne sont pas des
devins. Nous organisons les secours.
Les compagnons sont à l'intérieur.
Des dirigeants qui ne font rien.
Sylvia est seule.
Elle continue à se démener.
Elle continue d'acheter du ravitaillement.
Elle n'a plus d'argent pour payer.
Elle s'endette.
Il est toujours vivant ?
Je ne sais pas depuis hier soir.
Je ne sais pas dans quel état il est.
On y retourne maintenant.
Il a une chance ?
Oui, on l'espère.
Il est en vie !
Personne ne m'a aidé ce matin.
Les dirigeants ne font rien.
Attention où tu mets les mains,
ça peut s'effondrer.
5 h de l'après-midi, Damien, le jeune
mineur qui avait donné l'alerte,
sort du boyau.
Comment il va ?
Il va bien, il est vivant.
William vient d'être dégagé par ses amis.
William, c'est lui.
Il vient de passer
30 heures sous l'éboulis.
30 heures emmurées.
J'ai pensé à mes enfants et à ma femme.
J'ai beaucoup pensé.
J'ai cru que j'allais y rester,
qu'on n'allait pas m'en sortir.
Merci à tous mes compagnons.
Je ne peux rien dire d'autre.
C'est pour ta famille.
On a travaillé dur, très dur.
Il y avait trop de poussière.
Toute la nuit,
j'ai uriné dans ma bouteille.
J'ai bu mon urine,
c'est comme ça que j'ai tenu.
Mais les dernières heures,
je n'en pouvais plus, j'ai craqué.
Ne t'inquiète pas,
il va bien, il arrive.
Encore sous le choc, William
ne voit pas Sylvia, sa femme.
Mets cette couverture.
18 h, comme chaque soir après la mine,
Nikos attend Sandra.
Sandra, c'est important pour moi.
Elle me donne de la tendresse,
et elle est là
quand j'en ai besoin.
Quand je la vois,
ça me donne envie d'étudier,
de progresser pour m'en sortir,
m'en sortir pour elle.
Nous sommes des enfants de mineurs,
et ce n'est pas facile de s'en sortir.
On veut obtenir des diplômes,
avoir des enfants qui iront
encore plus loin que nous.
C'est ça s'en sortir.
- Ensemble ?
- Oui, ensemble.
Le plus important dans ma vie,
c'est mon futur avec Sandra.
Pour sortir de la mine, pour s'en sortir,
Nikos compte sur l'informatique.
Depuis un an, il se paye avec son argent
de poche un cours dans une école privée.
Tous les soirs de 20 h à 22 h.
L'objectif de Nikos : un diplôme
d'informaticien pour passer des concours,
afin d'entrer dans l'administration.
Le lendemain matin,
William, le rescapé,
il n'est pas allé à la mine.
Pas de blessure apparente.
Physiquement, aucune trace.
Physiquement...
Je ne veux pas retourner à la mine,
Je veux m'en aller.
Peut-être à mon village.
Vous avez été traumatisé ?
Oui, complètement.
Je ne redescendrai jamais à la mine.
Comment allez-vous faire
pour nourrir votre famille ?
Je veux redevenir
paysan dans mon village.
Ici, il n'y a rien à faire.
Je fais des cauchemars.
Jamais je ne retournerai à la mine.
Andres est retourné à la mine.
Il n'a toujours pas trouvé
de travail à la ville.